on continue dans cette émission de
décortiquer la la place du travail dans
nos vies dans la société française dans
un instant je vous propose le regard de
trois journalistes européens venus
d'Italie d'Allemagne et du Portugal mais
avant de les accueillir sur notre
plateau on va comparer notre système de
retraite avec celui de nos voisins et
c'est Reda rabbit qui s'y colle
Emmanuel Macron en est convaincu de très
fort à l'état elle est indispensable
quand on se compare en Europe et quand
on regarde la nécessité que nous avons
collectivement de préserver sauver notre
système de retraite par répartition
pourtant comparé au système français aux
autres systèmes en Europe est assez
délicat différents pays différents
régimes pour avoir des pays où la part
de la retraite par capitalisation va
être plus importante que ce que l'on a
en France aujourd'hui ça reste encore
une part toute petite moins de 5% des
des retraites servi aujourd'hui au
retraités viennent de système par
capitalisation dans certains pays
d'Europe on peut être à 30 40%. les
modes de calcul sont aussi différents en
France comme dans 14 autres pays de
l'Union européenne on calcule selon le
nombre d'années en Allemagne selon le
nombre de points en Italie ou en Suède
selon des comptes notionnels autrement
dit le nombre de cotisations versées sur
un compte virtuel autre carte
je les gags de départ très différents
selon les pays 5 ans d'écart entre la
France et l'Allemagne mais en y
regardant de plus près c'est une
comparaison qui ne tient pas le 62 ans
qui concerne la France est simplement
l'âge à partir duquel vous pouvez
demander
à partir en retraite des personnes ne
peuvent vous empêcher de le faire et
bien il n'y a pas cet âge en Allemagne
ou dans d'autres pays des gens partent
avant 67 ans en Allemagne les gens
partent avant 66 ans en Italie et il
subissent une décote et c'est en fait
une situation tout à fait comparable à
la situation française la durée de
cotisation est aussi mouvante dans une
Europe à 27 Question Retraite
comparaison comparaison notre réforme
des retraites vue par trois de nos
voisins européens Brita senberg bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directrice du bureau
parisien du journal d'air Spiegel Paolo
Lévy bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue à vous
aussi correspondent l'italien à Paris
pour l'agence de presse anne-sa ananas
de la presse portugaise évidemment émise
apalski est resté à mes côtés
éditorialistes pendant toute cette
émission Brita Sanders commence avec
vous comment la la presse allemande
peut-être votre opinion publique
juge-t-elle ce débat français sur les
retraites est-ce que est-ce que c'est
traité souvent d'en parler médias et
avec quel prisme quand c'est traité
c'est traité c'est observer et puis il y
a pas mal d'articles là-dessus et
les Allemands ils ont un peu du mal à
comprendre pourquoi il y a une telle
révolte et les manifestations des grèves
et tout ça sera quand même assez long
terme
à cause de si on regarde extérieurement
du passage de 62 à 64 ans à savoir que
maintenant nous on est à 66 si on sera à
231 à 67 en 2031 voilà
2031 voilà donc oui ils ont du mal à
comprendre et si on regarde juste les
années c'est vrai que c'est difficile
à saisir comme conflit mais bon comme
j'essaie d'expliquer qu'il y a plein
d'autres choses derrière donc il faut
rentrer dans les détails mais c'est vrai
que les Allemands d'une façon générale
je crois ils ont une autre relation par
rapport au travail que les Français on
va peut-être en parler évidemment on va
prendre le temps de d'expliquer ces
différences pas obligé en Italie c'est
une réforme jugée courageuse nécessaire
injuste j'imagine ça dépend de quelle
famille politique on vient la vie oui
absolument en disant en Italie cette
réforme française
a suscité un peu de surprises pour de
raisons fondamentale la première c'est
les Italiens c'est vraiment les Français
n'ont pas encore réformé leur système
alors que nous on l'a fait cette réforme
désormais il y a 12 ans en passant de 62
63 ans à 77
en termes de recul de l'âge et ensuite
voilà la deuxième question c'est c'est
aussi celle de se dire mais avec cette
espérance de vie qui est plus ou moins
semblable à celle italienne et un taux
de natalité
qui recule malgré tout malgré soit un
des plus forts en Europe ici en France
devant mais où vont-ils puiser l'argent
parce que là c'est une question aussi
arithmétique nous on a une réforme des
retraites en 2011 qui fut très très dur
je vous dis seulement que notre ministre
du Travail de l'époque elle s'appelait
la vie annoncer en sanglots face caméra
en appelant parce que le système était
en faillite alors parce que tout
simplement c'était un contexte très
particulier et beaucoup plus pressant
par rapport à la France on était en
pleine crise économique et financière
Italie risquait de faire des fautes de
faire faillite comme la graisse donc il
y avait
urgence de réformer ce système mais on
peut dire que 12 ans après aujourd'hui
quasiment plus personne mis à part
l'extrême droite de Mateo Salvini remet
en cause la légitimité de cette réforme
qui a permis
néanmoins de sauver notre système par
répartition qui est quand même l'orgueil
de l'Europe c'est-à-dire de beaucoup de
pays européens c'est à dire c'est
aussi le système français évidemment
double question on part à la à quel âge
à la retraite au Portugal et puis quel
regard aussi voilà les médias ou les ou
les Portugais portent sur ce temps
politique là en France
de vie d'accord
l'espérance vie diminue au Portugal et
elle a diminué à cause du covid comme
dans tous les pays
occidentaux et elle diminue aussi elle
continue à diminuer à cause de ces excès
de mort cette mort subite adulte que
nous avons maintenant dans les pays dans
beaucoup de pays depuis un an ou un an
et demi environ donc elle était à 66 ans
et 7 mois et elle va passer maintenant à
66 ans et 4 mois donc elle évolue il
évolue en fonction de l'espérance de vie
d'accord donc c'est une réforme qui a
été fait très technique qui a été faite
à partir de 2005 et plusieurs années il
a été assez contrairement à l'Italie il
y avait pas eu un drame immense il y a
une énorme pédagogie c'est au départ un
choc on va choisir sur l'espérance vie
mais ça ça fait un peu mal et en même
temps ça finalement ça a été accepté on
avait les chiffres on savait le nombre
d'actifs le nombre le portillon a un
taux de natalité très bas contrairement
à la France donc sont des éléments
mendis par rapport à comment la presse
analyse cette réforme en France
maintenant il y a ça aussi qui est mise
en avant la natalité en France c'est
quelque chose qui est mis en avant très
différent il y a un taux de natalité
très bas au Portugal depuis très
longtemps et en France il a commencé
seulement depuis deux ans abaisser donc
il y avait un renouvellement de la
population au moins en France il y avait
des infrastructures en France pour la
natalité qui ont maintenant les jeunes
les trentenaires si on les écoute on
sait très bien quelle est la difficulté
d'avoir un enfant aujourd'hui
par manque d'infrastructures si la mère
travaille le père travaille donc et donc
au Portugal on remarque aussi je
souvent en avant ici mais on remarque
aussi qu'il y avait une autre différence
c'est que en France on a vu venir cette
inversion du nombre de actifs pour le
nombre de retraités puisque c'est par
répartition comme chez nous et donc sont
ceux qui travaillent qui payent en
principe les retraites des retraites les
pensions des retraités et bien on on a
bien remarqué le fait qu'il y avait eu
quand même une mesure je pensais le seul
pays en Europe qui avait mis un fond du
temps de Lionel Jospin Premier ministre
qui avait mis un fond un Madeleine pour
justement pallier à ce problème et
préserver ce système de retraite par
répartition bon on voit aussi que
évidemment comme tout gouvernement tout
le mouvement français ont bien piocher
dedans ce bas de laine est bien diminué
par rapport à ce qui devait être mais
qu'il y a quand même cela et puis on
dernière chose on ne comprend pas la
différence il y a des économistes en
France qui disent non il y a pas
d'urgence vraiment puis on a d'autres
qui disent le gouvernement qui dit oui
c'est urgent sinon on va être en
faillite et entre que les arguments sont
très bons et puis si on n'est pas un
spécialiste de du domaine on a du mal à
plusieurs journées on l'a dit si on
comprenait plus grand chose mais
effectivement ce le rapport du Conseil
de rotation des retraites c'est vrai que
il y a eu il y a eu deux lectures il y a
eu des lectures très différentes je vais
vous donner la parole évidemment Paolo
mais alors je voulais vous connaissez
sûrement cette expression qui était
l'expression favorite je crois d'un
ancien Premier ministre québécois qui
disait quand je me regarde je me désole
quand je me compare je me console donc
on va beaucoup se comparer dans cette
dans cette émission je vous propose
tiens de regarder le budget qu'on peut
consacré aux retraites en pourcentage du
PIB sont des chiffres qui date de 2019
on voit que l'Allemagne il consacre un
peu plus de 10% en Belgique 10,7
l'Espagne 11,3 le Portugal 12,4 la
France 14,5 et l'Italie
15,9%
Paul Olivier est-ce que ce budget
important il est lié à la place que les
familles accorde aux personnes âgées au
seniors aux grands-parents chez eux tout
simplement comment vous l'expliquez ça
absolument je pense qu'il y a de ça
c'est c'est quand même une part très
importante que pèse les retraites dans
dans nos budgets dans les principales
économies de la zone euro on est tous
plus ou moins dans un ordre de grandeur
et là il y a des différences assez
importantes entre l'Italie et
l'Allemagne je vais venir à l'exemple
allemand
les Allemands ils ont fait une grande
réforme au début des années 2000 qui a
rationalisé tout cela l'Italie a une
population très vieillissante et donc ça
pèse énormément on l'a vu aussi avec le
covid pourquoi on a été les premières
victimes tout de suite de du virus parce
que on a une population très très âgée
et ça ça explique beaucoup de choses
après je reviens à un moment sur ce que
disait Anna c'est vrai et il y a
différents économistes qui disent
l'urgence pas l'urgence etc une chose
est sûre vu d'Italie nous on a dû
réparer en toi en plein orage et disons
il est généralement beaucoup plus
judicieux de réparer le toit quand il y
a moins d'urgence quand la météo est
encore moyennement bonne on est bien
d'accord britisenberg je reprends ce
chiffre 10,4 % du du produit intérieur
brut consacré aux retraites en Allemagne
est-ce que ça veut dire que les pensions
de retraite sont moins favorables ou
confortables qu'en France par exemple
complètement et puis les Allemands quand
on regarde les cotisation cotisent aussi
moi pour la retraite enfin c'est
inférieur j'ai le chiffre là c'est donc
c'est moins important qu'en France et je
crois que ça il y a toute une autre
logique aussi par rapport à la retraite
d'un travailleur allemand d'un employé
allemand quand un employé français moi
j'ai l'impression que les Français
vivent la retraite comme un temps où ils
vivent à salaire réduite puisque quand
on regarde ce qui reste de enfin il y a
des chiffres de l'OCD qui prennent comme
base le salaire moyen d'un employeur
d'un employé et
et en France je crois qu'on revient à
74% à peu près de du salaire net de ce
enfin ça change après de c'est difficile
à comparer mais si on compare le salaire
c'est quand même un moyen le salaire
moyen on arrive à avoir quelque chose
normalement c'est beaucoup moins 52%.
donc c'est vraiment la moitié après donc
on commence par quoi par un système de
capitalisation
ils sont conscients qu'ils doivent
eux-mêmes enfin ils sont beaucoup plus
responsables aussi de de leur fin de vie
c'est-à-dire que soit leurs entreprises
leur offre des assurances en plus ou une
retraite d'entreprise ça existe ça
dépend de la taille et de la motivation
de l'entreprise ou alors et eux-mêmes
ils font des assurances vie où ils
achètent de l'immobilier enfin c'est pas
cette cette attitude l'État va faire que
à la fin de ma carrière ou après ma
carrière professionnelle je vais avoir
non pas un salaire mais quelque chose
qui s'y rapproche et en plus en France
vous avez beaucoup plus de couples où
les deux ont travaillé toute leur vie ça
a changé maintenant en Allemagne et les
analysant mais pendant très longtemps
les femmes restaient très longtemps à la
maison pour garder des enfants puisqu'on
a pas on n'avait pas non plus ces
infrastructures de crèche de garde
d'enfants ou alors travailler à mi-temps
donc n'avaient des retraites encore
beaucoup plus misérables donc c'est à
dire que cette envie de vouloir passer à
enfin être retraités pour profiter de la
vie est aussi limiter rien que par les
moyens financiers comparer la France
assez voisins européens pour justifier
cette réforme ça a été Émilie l'un des
arguments des guides mais il y en a eu
beaucoup d'autres aussi depuis le début
du feuilleton autour des retraites le
gouvernement est utilisé plusieurs
arguments pour justifier sa réforme on a
eu le droit au départ à la nécessité de
financer la santé l'éducation la
transition écologique et puis après on
avait une réforme viser plutôt la
justice sociale mais il y a eu quelques
quoi que au niveau du gouvernement
notamment sur la carrière des femmes et
des carrières longues ça empêchait le
gouvernement de continuer sur cet axe de
communication qui a opté du coup pour un
discours beaucoup plus basique simple en
gros la réforme est indispensable pour
sauver notre système par répartition
Gabriel latale le disait très très
clairement à l'Assemblée nationale donc
le ministre chargé des comptes publics
c'était le 6 février 2023 on l'écoute
n'ayons pas peur de le dire en matière
de retraite mesdames et messieurs les
députés c'est une réforme ou la faillite
c'est ça la réalité de notre système
aujourd'hui alors c'était un peu moins
pressant encore en Italie mais en tout
cas c'était l'argument qui était utilisé
et il y a eu aussi celui de la
comparaison à l'Europe mais qui n'a pas
fait long feu lui non et pourtant si je
me souviens même manuel Macron en a
reparlé la retenté le coup récemment
c'est ça il a déclaré fin janvier depuis
les Pays-Bas que la réforme des
retraites est indispensable quand tout
son quand on se compare à l'Europe on
l'a vu tout à l'heure c'est vrai que le
départ la retraite à 70 ans est une
exception française quasiment en Europe
la plupart des pays comme on l'a vu
affichant beaucoup plus tardivement cet
âge 65 jusqu'à 67 ans bientôt en
Allemagne et déjà au Danemark et en
Italie mais quand on se penche dans les
détails et on l'a vu aussi dans le
reportage c'est un petit peu plus
variable selon ce qu'on compare et puis
selon l'âge effectif du départ à la
retraite et les pensions qui sont
effectivement reçus et puis alors
puisqu'on est dans la comparaison avec
des échos négatifs arrivés de Suède
alors oui il manque de chance en janvier
je sais pas si vous souvenez un
responsable suédois pas n'importe lequel
c'est celui qui a initié la réforme des
retraites en Suède et notamment le
passage à 65 ans dans son pays il a mis
en garde la France à ce moment là
récemment il a dit oui à la réforme mais
à une réforme à la française surtout ne
suivez pas le modèle suédois et pourquoi
parce que beaucoup de suédois ont trouvé
que c'était trop difficile et ils ont
décidé de partir trois ans à l'avance 65
ans c'était trop compliqué mais du coup
ils partaient avec des toutes petites
pensions
résultat en 2019 on a mesuré après la
réforme du système 72% des Suédois à la
retraite et jusqu'à 92% des Suédoises à
la retraite ont subi une baisse de leur
pension et de leur pouvoir d'achat alors
ça pas empêcher le Danemark de prévoir
un départ à la retraite à 70 ans en 2040
mais finalement cette idée d'exception
française qui nous a été soufflée par ce
Suédois elle est pas si idiote elle
pourrait faire son chemin plus de 6
Français sur 10 estiment de toute façon
qu'une réforme est nécessaire mais ils
avancent d'autres solutions que le
report de l'âge à la retraite qui est
prenait par l'exécutif par exemple de
l'augmentation des cotisations
patronales par exemple de la taxation du
capital des plus riches de la
contribution des retraités ça c'est un
peu un sujet tabou ou encore délégalité
salariale entre les hommes et les femmes
on termine là-dessus qu'est-ce qu'on
peut en dire alors cette mesure elle est
pas mal parce que d'après les syndicats
ça permettrait de générer 5 milliards
d'euros par an et puis finalement ça
permettrait de se comparer aux Européens
d'une manière un petit peu plus positive
parce qu'on n'est pas parmi les
meilleurs élèves dans ce domaine l'écart
entre les salaires des hommes et des
femmes en France et autour de 16% contre
test 13% en moyenne en Europe et il y a
le gagnant qui est le Luxembourg moins
de 1% donc c'est peut-être un nouveau
défi européen à relever
en entreprise égalité salariale au
Portugal c'est un débat qui a été
adressé il y a quelques années ou alors
vous êtes plutôt en retard sur cette
question
dans les autres pays européens les
femmes sont pénalisées dans dans ce
domaine
sauf le Luxembourg
ils sont pas nombreux elles sont pas
nombreuses donc ça fait pas beaucoup de
population
c'était car entre femmes et en mélasse
mais vous savez parfois aller chercher
chez les autres les solutions chez les
autres au à Bruxelles parce que les
autres font il faut faire aussi sans
regarder exactement et là je reviens
évidemment à la réforme des retraites
parfois faut faire attention aussi il
faut je vous disais que dans la presse
sportive ils ont fait attention aux
éléments spécifiques de la situation en
France je vous donne un exemple
portugais dans un autre tout un domaine
pas mal d'années quand on avait la crise
d'être souveraine
c'était aussi au moment où l'Europe
était vraiment dans le libéralisme total
économique et c'était aussi au moment la
libre concurrence c'était un dogme
intouchable en Europe il fallait à ce
titre là on finir avec les ménopoles de
temps notamment dans des domaines qui
tiennent à la souveraineté des États
l'électricité par exemple est porté elle
a dû
privatiser sa compagnie d'électricité
l'équivalent de dés à fond en France
monopole d'État et qui a acheté bah le
meilleur offrant et qui était le
meilleur offrant une compagnie chinoise
d'État donc l'électricité au Portugal
n'est plus un monopole d'État portugais
c'est monopole détachinois avec une
petite participation d'hormones
donc vous voyez parfois l'Europe aussi
ne nous donne pas des
des idées d'une intelligence absolue en
sous-estime l'incompétence
et
en surestime d'intelligence de ce qui
nous dicte alors loi on va continuer de
se comparer pour pour ne pas se désoler
je vous propose tiens c'est cette source
c'est l'OCDE qui nous propose sur la
question de l'équilibre entre vie
professionnelle et vie personnelle le
nombre d'heures quotidiennes consacrées
aux loisirs et aux occupations
personnelles dormir manger par exemple
le Portugal tient est à 15h seulement
parce que si on regarde les autres pays
la Suède c'est 15,3 l'Allemagne 15,6 le
Danemark ça monte etc etc on va chercher
ensuite la France à
16,2 je sais pas si vous avez cette
infographie à nous montrer et ensuite
l'Italie à 16,5 on ne l'a pas mais donc
je vous redonne les chiffres importants
qui concernent nos pays le Portugal est
à 15 heures de de on va dire de vie
personnelle
l'Allemagne est à 15h,6 la France a 16
heures virgule en Italie à 16h,5 Paolo
Lévy comment vous vous analysez notre
équilibre Vie privée vie personnelle ici
en France dit on est le pays de
Descartes et ça se ressent d'une
certaine façon oui exactement je trouve
que
ici en France il y a une dichotomie très
nette entre le temps de travail et le
temps de loisirs on le voit aussi par le
vocabulaire paradoxalement de lieu de
travail parfois on l'appelle je dois
aller à la boire
les moments où on n'est pas au travail
on les appelle des moments d'évasion il
y a presque même une allée en prison je
dirais presque claustrophobie ou
pénitentiaire par rapport au travail
c'est pas le cas en Italie c'est plus
fluide quoi d'une certaine façon en
Italie exactement c'est peut-être parce
que il y a
plus de légèreté je sais pas mais on
arrive quand même à avoir plus de
fluidité entre ces deux cases de la vie
et cela est dû à mon avis aussi au fait
que je pense qu'ici en France le rapport
au travail est beaucoup plus hiérarchisé
beaucoup plus dur beaucoup plus
concurrentiel et compétitif aussi alors
qu'en Italie
on cherche de transformer disons
l'expérience professionnelle
non seulement quelque chose voilà de
gain productif de salaire etc mais aussi
dans une forme d'épanouissement
personnel des changes entre vous savez
la Constitution italienne a mis à son
premier article article 1 de la
Constitution c'est l'Italie est une
république fondée sur le travail et le
travail encore aujourd'hui est perçu
plutôt comme une valeur très positive
c'est un pays qui a beaucoup souffert du
chômage c'est un beau pays qui a
beaucoup de émigré dans d'autres pays et
même outre-Atlantique pour chercher un
travail donc le travail moi j'ai suivi
tous les cortèges de l'arc disons des
syndicats ces derniers mois et parfois
on peint vraiment ce travail comme si
c'était une corvée
insupportable alors qu'en Italie il n'y
a pas trop cette perception on a plutôt
le problème donc le discours sur le
travail aliénant parce que c'est un peu
ça on l'entend assez peu en Italie c'est
ce que vous nous dites et nous on a
plutôt un autre discours inverse
paradoxalement c'est drôle parce que
c'est vraiment tout un autre débat
opposé à la France c'est plutôt les
jeunes Italiens qui ont beaucoup de mal
à accéder au marché du travail parce que
les seniors ne veulent pas lâcher
jusqu'au bout il s'épanouissent au
travail et travail jusqu'à très très
tard et et à mon avis cela relève voilà
aussi d'une année ça c'est mon une idée
que j'ai élucubrer moi de façon
personnelle c'est tout c'est que les
élucubrations de Paul Olivier
des cartes qui est disons un grand
héritage français donc les mathématiques
la ration ayant les a déclinés aussi
dans les rapports professionnels et
sociaux au travail ce qui peut rendre
parfois le travail un peu aliénant je
vous fais un exemple très très simple
boulangère depuis 10 ans je vais acheter
la baguette chez elle et elle me répète
tous les jours la même frappe bonjour
bonsoir avec ce je vais chez mon
boulanger à Rome chaque jour il me dit
une chose différente et donc ça rend
aussi le travail plus amusant chaque
jour
comme comme panorama mais est-ce que
justement on en parlait tout à l'heure
dans les fonctions peut-être à l'hôpital
est-ce que c'est aussi des tâches qui
sont arrivées est-ce que les gens
souhaitent travailler longtemps
peut-être dans l'industrie aussi les
ouvriers est-ce que c'est la même chose
parce que j'imagine que c'est quand même
ça dépend un peu de quel type de travail
qui est joyeux et puis
c'était un tableau un peu général il y a
des métiers usurants moi-même j'ai fait
l'ouvrier mais j'ai même constaté que
quand je travaillais dans les chantiers
dans la banlieue de Rome même la bas à
5h du matin on cherchait quand même d'un
soufflet à l'esprit de bonne humeur au
travail qui qui aide beaucoup qui aide
beaucoup dans la résolution de la
vitesse and black quand vous comparez
les Français les Allemands dans dans
leur rapport au travail qu'est-ce qui
vous fera pour prioritairement ce qui me
frappe c'est que
en suivant le les discussions
françaises et aussi l'attitude des
Français par rapport à leur travail on a
on a quand même parfois l'impression que
le travail est ressenti comme une
souffrance et que la retraite de l'autre
côté comme une récompense comme ce qu'on
a dû subir jusqu'à là
je crois que c'est aussi pour ça que la
contestation est tellement
violente puisque les gens considèrent
qu'ils ont mérité cette retraite sur
tout dans des professions et dures
puisqu'ils ont souffert étant donné ils
étaient mal payés avant mais c'est pas
le cas c'est ce que disait Émilie
concernité il y a aussi des métiers très
durs en Allemagne
il y a des emplois qui sont mal
rémunérés aussi donc
du travail en Allemagne
pourtant le rapport au travail et pas le
même c'est pas la même chose puisque je
crois que tout d'abord les et aussi dans
les professions non académiques
considère que le travail est aussi une
manière d'une d'un accomplissement de
soi d'une réaction réalisation
personnelle de quelque chose qui vous
permet de vous épanouir et d'avancer
aussi de changer de statut
éventuellement c'est un peu l'esprit
américain peut être de on peut commencer
très très bas et arriver
dans un autre dans une autre classe
sociale aussi ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième c'est qu'on a des
hiérarchies qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les vôtres c'est à dire que votre
culture de management est quand même
toujours marqué par une hiérarchie très
verticale et à quelqu'un ça change
peut-être un peu mais en Allemagne
depuis longtemps il y a c'est plus
horizontal oui c'est plusieurs après
évidemment vous pouvez pas ça dépend de
les entreprises mais d'une façon
générale une entreprise moderne
maintenant ou qui se veut moderne ne
peut plus se permettre certaines choses
et cette
la santé que les syndicats qui sont non
pas politiques mais par branche
organisée par branche vont participer en
vraiment une grande influence et un
grand pouvoir sur
plus puissants mais il y a moins de
manifestations il y a des manifestations
aussi là il y en a un qui est une qui
sera annoncé cette semaine un peu moins
qu'en France et un peu moins de grève
mais il y a un vrai c'est un vrai levier
et il y a des négociations il y a pas
négociation ça veut dire que les deux
doivent chacun doit laisser des plumes
on va grâce à un effet légisment comparé
un peu sur cette question des tensions
sociales Yann vous devez être là et
pouvoir me rejoindre oui c'est parti
bonsoir Yann il y a pas mal de pays qui
sont actuellement secoué par des
mouvements de protestation y compris
ceux qui sont pas vraiment habitués à la
grève oui parce que si la réforme des
retraites est propre à la France la
colère elle ne l'est pas regardez les
images qui vont s'afficher derrière moi
c'était à Lisbonne au Portugal pas plus
tard que samedi des milliers de
personnes dans les rues pour protester
contre la flambée des prix l'inflation a
presque atteint les 8% l'an dernier dans
le pays une partie de la population n'en
peut plus écouter l'exemple de cette
retraité
j'ai 70 ans j'ai travaillé toute ma vie
j'ai une retraite misérable et je risque
de me retrouver à la rue alors que je
loue un petit appartement depuis 48 ans
ils veulent mettre les vieux à la rue et
ce n'est pas juste ça fait 48 ans que je
paye mon loyer et comme je suis retraité
je ne peux pas aller ailleurs c'est pour
cela que je suis ici
de multiples secteurs qui se sont mis à
l'arrêt les trains les écoles les
ambulances une situation quasiment
similaire au Royaume-Uni sauf que sur
l'île l'inflation dépasse les 10% et
chose rares ces dernières années chez
les Britanniques le pays est secoué par
des grèves depuis quelques mois les
ambulanciers en tout cas 15000 d'entre
eux ont une nouvelle fois arrêté le
travail en ce début février
notre quatrième jour de grève et les
gens continuent à faire grève jusqu'à ce
que les portes soient ouvertes pour que
notre syndicat puisse entrer et
commencer les négociations mais pour le
moment le gouvernement n'écoute pas il
ne veut pas nous recevoir
nous n'aimons pas faire grève ce n'est
pas utile ce n'est pas génial pour le
public
car s'ils ont le sentiment de ne pas se
faire entendre c'est parce que le
gouvernement britannique peine à trouver
une réponse face à la hausse des prix le
Premier ministre Martel que des hausses
de salaire pourrait justement aggraver
l'inflation et puis on en parlait à
l'instant avec Bota même l'Allemagne est
concerné oui on pense souvent à
l'Allemagne comme un pays de négociation
on parle même souvent du modèle allemand
de cogestion où l'implication des
salariés permettrait d'éviter les
conflits et bien regardez ces images
c'était il y a tout juste 11 jours à
Francfort l'aéroport paralysé à cause
d'une grève du personnel en tout huit
plateformes dans le pays étaient à
l'arrêt le syndicat la manœuvre réclame
de meilleurs salaires pour les employés
au sol les négociations avec la
direction n'ayant rien donné ils ont
côté pour une journée de grève en
Allemagne aussi ce sont les records
d'inflation plus de 10% qui ont tendu
les négociations salariales dans
l'ensemble des secteurs d'activités et
cette colère ne concerne pas que les
aéroports la poste en Allemagne a aussi
été perturbé par plusieurs jours de
grève merci Yann britishenderesse avec
vous puis ensuite on parlera évidemment
du Portugal mais vous nous décriviez
finalement un système bien huilé de
négociation par branche est-ce que le
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie et
les conséquences économiques de la
guerre ça
détraqué un peu le le processus de de
négociation voilà est-ce que l'inflation
finalement met à mal le système
ce que je vous ai décrit ça ne veut pas
dire que tout qui a jamais eu de grève
ou des mensuration les négociations
étaient aussi dures mais il y a il y a
ce que je voulais dire c'est qu'il y a
un processus qui est installé par depuis
les décennies avec ses négociations
entre employeurs et syndicats et quand
c'est l'entreprise qui donne pas
seulement l'impression mais que qui fait
vraiment que les employés en plus
d'influence sur sur leur lieu de travail
et les conditions de travail que en
France après il va y avoir une grève de
annoncé pas Verdi ce qu'on vient de voir
à la fin de la semaine à nouveau et
c'est sûr que plus la pression
économiquement et on a une inflation qui
tourne je crois que c'est à 10,6% en ce
moment plus les questions deviennent
urgentes donc je veux pas dire que tout
est rose en Allemagne mais ce qui fait
que la relation par rapport à au travail
n'est pas
défini comme comme en France ou parfois
vraiment cette presque haine envers les
employeurs ou cette ce sentiment de de
souffrance quand on peut ressentir de
beaucoup de frustration sur une
injustice aussi du monde de travail
je crois que ça c'est moins prononcé en
Allemagne donc on n'est pas idéal
partout mais parfait partout mais il y a
il y a plusieurs facteurs qui font que
que ça c'est différent mais évidemment
on a aussi des manifestations et des
grèves on le voit ananas on a bien vu il
y a ce ce finalement ce mouvement social
lié à l'inflation et essentiellement et
pas que alors c'est quoi parce que
l'inflation est venue aggraver une
situation qui se prolongeait depuis
justement j'en parlais tout à l'heure de
la crise de la dette souveraine au
Portugal et à ce moment-là nous les
avancements de carrière ont été gelés
carrément par exemple les professeurs on
voit souvent les professeurs dans la rue
tous les points que tout toutes les
promotions et toutes les augmentations
de salaires dépend du nombre de points
dans une carrière
le professeur du secteur public et
évidemment tout ça a été gelé donc ça
fait maintenant 11 ans 12 ans que les
professeurs n'ont pas eu de réel
augmentation ni d'avancement de carrière
donc à chaque fois on leur a demandé de
tenir bon ils ont tenu bon jusqu'à
maintenant parce que l'inflation là a
rattrapé en plus aggraver et des
conditions de le pouvoir d'achat les
conditions de vie après au gouvernant a
pris beaucoup de mesures pour le
combustible pour les loyers etc mais par
exemple dans le cas des loyers il n'a
pas prévu l'économie portugaise est très
interdit d'augmentation qui dépasserait
je veux donner un chiffre parce que j'ai
un peu oublié là hélas mais peut-être
10% sauf que au Portugal c'est pas une
économie réglementée comme la France et
donc les les propriétaires ont tout
simplement
et il y avait une compensation pour les
propriétaires payés par l'État mais ils
ont tout simplement résilié les contrats
et présenter au locataire d'autres
contrats avec un loyer beaucoup plus
élevé et c'est tu acceptes quelque part
quoi donc
il y a cette situation extrêmement
entendue au Portugal et puis les
retraites sont très bon marché même si
ça représente une grande partie du PIB
comme on avait tout à l'heure c'est
parce que le PIB est mort au Portugal
aussi depuis la crise et
la crise financière qu'on ne leur a pas
connu en 2016 et bien le portion n'a pas
encore attrapé le pouvoir d'achat et il
richesse à la production qu'il avait
avant donc il y a un dernier thème dont
je vais parler dans dans ce débat le
temps à filer bien vite pour voir si
c'est une spécificité française ou pas
celui des régimes spécieux et je vous
propose pour lancer ce thème d'écouter
le président du groupe LR au Sénat Bruno
retailleux puisque c'est l'un des
aspects sur lesquels la majorité de
droite du Sénat veut faire évoluer la
réforme des retraites
une proposions pas la cause qu'on perd
je pense que je préférerais moi par
exemple et nous l'étudierons pourquoi
pas que on puisse avoir cette
trajectoire qui permette de rapprocher
justement les régimes spéciaux du régime
général de la Sécurité sociale parce
qu'il y a une injustice regardez la RATP
ou en part des régimes où on parle le
plus tôt où on a une retraite moyenne
qui est l'une des plus élevées est-ce
que tout ça allait juste Paolo Olivier
est-ce que c'est une une anomalie ou une
spécificité française les relations de
cet envergure peut-être oui bien sûr on
a des régimes spéciaux en Italie aussi
mais là je pense que en France ils sont
17 plus plus ou moins c'est pour ça que
c'est un peu dommage d'avoir perdu cette
première réforme systémique qu'Emmanuel
Macron avait présenté lors du précédent
quinquennat parce que là c'était une
vraie réforme d'envergure qui remettait
à plat tous les régimes spéciaux un
système universel qui à mon avis se
marier très très bien avec un des
principes clés de votre devise
républicaine qui est l'égalité et et là
c'est c'est dommage parce que
aujourd'hui il y a une réforme qui est
bien plus moins ambitieuse que l'autre
et je pense que tout le monde il y a
toujours les mêmes qui vont préserver
disons leur statut et leur privilèges
mais il y en a d'autres qui sont
complètement laissés par là-haut mer
ouverte je pense par exemple aux oubliés
de nos sociétés les caissières de les
caissiers des supermarchés et les
éboueurs tous ces nouveaux métiers qui
ont émergé avec Internet les livreurs on
les voit dans le pari et dans nos
grandes villes ils ont aucune protection
et non même pas le pouvoir de bloquer un
pays comme en revanche peuvent le faire
les employés de SNCF ou de leur et donc
c'est juste que la réforme finalement
telle qu'on nous la propose se
cristallise autour des 64 ans elle a pas
beaucoup plus d'ambition par rapport à
la réforme qui a été abandonnée en 2019
et par rapport à ce qu'on a dit c'est
vrai que elles sont jamais remises en
question finalement on avance sauf dans
le cas portugais puisque vous basez sur
la la durée de vie en fait l'espérance
de vie mais autant y aller très fort
puisque on n'a pas l'urgence que vous
avez eu en Italie et en plus de toute
façon on sait que c'est des réformes
dures et que la plupart du temps aucun
gouvernement suivant ne remet en
question donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
quelque chose d'un petit peu dommage
pour secouer tout le pays comme ça pour
finalement enfin c'est déjà gros deux
ans de plus mais on aurait pu en
profiter pour d'autres choses c'est non
mais plus ambitieuse ça fait beaucoup de
bruit enfin beaucoup de mouvements pour
finalement si le gouvernement voulait y
aller autant qu'il est à fond et
peut-être c'est un petit peu ce qui a
été raté par rapport à il y a deux ans
encore
vous nous disent vous nous disiez vous
nous expliquer le finalement le le
système de négociation par branche en
Allemagne le les syndicats sont
puissants là-bas est-ce qu'ils ont
utilisé leur puissance pour sauvegarder
des régimes spéciaux je reste sur notre
dernier thème
il y en a quelques-uns pour comme
partout pour les militaires pour pour la
police pour tous ces mais des
professions quoi un pouvoir de blocage
comme comme l'avoir certaines
professions en France oui je crois qu'il
y a certaines conducteurs de train qui
peuvent partir plus tôt mais c'est pas
vraiment là-dessus qu'ils ont enfin ma
connaissance c'est pas vraiment c'était
pas vraiment le sujet non et c'est pas
forcément dans la culture
allemande cette culture du blocage ou ça
arrive de blocage ou de je crois qu'il y
avait d'autres d'autres sujets qu'il
trouvait plus importants que que de
créer des régimes spéciaux c'est quand
même vraiment quelque chose de bien
français aussi après bon il y a
il y a cette
idée salle de dartek Cloud c'est-à-dire
que ceux qui qui font les toits et qui
montent sur les toits c'est à dire que
évidemment il y a certaines professions
ou rien que physiquement c'est plus
possible
de monter jusqu'à 67 ans sur sur les
toits
il y a des égards et puis moi je trouve
que on en a pas du tout parlé nous les
seniors c'est quand même complètement
autre chose et on trouve même pour ces
professions là donc qui sont durs des
moyens des employés on essaie de les
employer de faire travailler autrement
merci beaucoup on en avait beaucoup
parlé dans la première partie c'est pour
ça aussi merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je vous dis à demain pour un
nouveau numéro de sciences publiques qui
sera évidemment consacré à la réforme
des retraites avec notamment un débat
entre sénateurs dans notre seconde
partie d'émission et puis votre
prochaine invité politique sur notre
antenne dans la matinale Hervé Marseille
sénateur des Hauts-de-Seine président du
groupe Union centriste il sera face à
Oriane Mancini à 8 heures du matin belle
soirée